this is a new thing sort of we are
finished filling you up our work on
vegan lives this is the last thing i
want to show you about the others but
now before we get to parametric
equations of your lips which comes a bit
later um this is important this is
actually a big deal and that's kind of
why leaving is heading blame because I
can't show it to you can't tell you what
the heading is that kind of spoiling
what's going to emerge out of it okay so
this is a very very important result it
should be done properly and it can't be
done properly in a fully algebraic way
in other words in other words when x
squared a squared Y squared b squared
equals one and they just deal with ease
and ease and beads of a lie kind of
thing for a couple of reasons I'm not
going to do that first start if I just
deal with actual numbers a lot of stuff
will simplify out and the algebra will
not be too involved we'll have a look at
the fill out to write proof I'm going to
be later I'll show it to you it's all
written in the phaser colors one happy
but I think it's a bit it didn't
confusing as to why you would do that
before you see what I'm going to show
okay so let's call back to my this
ellipse you know how I have my favorite
quadratic this is the equivalent for
your lips is my favorite so I keep on
going back to this because it has
relatively simple numbers okay now we
actually determined that the amtrak I of
this ellipse are plus or minus root 7
comments here so it's it's all the major
axis being horizontally so I've gone out
that far okay now noticing that like
picking in terms of the waters right
you've got a whole bunch of points Pig
where they according to x and y such
that the distances to hear at least
which will always be some proportion of
the distance to the directrix or the
director seat at your table that's all
fine I want do something a little bit
unusual
and less sort of obvious which is to say
you have this too photo right and we
said well you've got one it's
symmetrical so you get another one it's
kind of like it's just there right my
question is though do they have more of
a relationship to each other the
Whispering Gallery is where we started
very beginning of product kind of
suggests that actually the foci are
related to each other not just there by
accident so I'm going to try and
demonstrate the relationship between
them by a similar the phone goes to
different things so you might remember
we used to on the prabal our column s
life that's the focus so be that there
too i'm going to call it SNS dash now if
I des idées wonderful positive one was
the negative one I can start to do some
work with this right so in particular I
am interested in generally speaking what
is the distance from my point to the
focus so when I say generally I mean 480
XY pair that's formed the lockers okay
so how I work out this distance p.s it's
just two plates right here's a point
here's a pair of walnuts and here's
another one so let's just give this a
crack right this is going to be the
square root R and I've got x2 minus x1
squared and then y2 y1 sweat you care
with that lucky too dramatic then now i
can simplify this a little bit right now
i know that there's going to be some
stuff that can simplify here because
even though book explains and Y
Squared's at the moment underneath the
square root X when my squares are kind
of interchangeable but like just a
straight swap but this equation up here
tells me there's a relationship between
x and y okay so that suggests to me I
should be able to
eliminate one of these variables now I
can look at it x squared out or I can
limit it why sweat out just because y
squared is on his own I think that will
be easier to do to have a look at this
line for a second before we march off
with our work if i were to make y
squared the subjects of that equation of
ellipse what I get what should i do what
i do first yeah I'll do that time over
that gives me this yeah and then I'm
just going to multiply through our time
right that gives me this
okay now this is good I mean it looks a
bit messy but I can still work with it
because it's just going to hear me
everything in terms of X Squared's so
I'm hoping my figures are crossing that
there's going to be some collection of
like terms that these could simplify out
in some way so let's have a cracked egg
standing is this part here is going to
become and it's just going to expand a
perfect square so if we x squared latest
su root 7 X plus 7 good and then instead
of writing Y square here i'm going to
substitute that from this guy okay so
i'm getting no line take away this any x
squared and that's all under big square
okay so you can see as I was hoping for
I'll not just one by two these two terms
are both going to collapse into the
terms that i got from bob extending is
square right so let's collect some
things together i've got the square root
of ok how many x squared terms do I
haven't live 596 yeah it's one of them
here and I take away nine sixteenths of
one here so that leaves me with 76 days
of one here you care with that what are
the X terms anything happen out there
just stays good doesn't it to realtor
and then here I've got plus 7 plus sign
+ c state I look okay happy so far
motifs to route 7
oh sorry yes that's a nice thing very
good ok so that's right on ok now look
at that stare out at heart this is
believe it or not as easy as it gets
it's got the list over exert I could
possibly put it to it and we're
certainly less than algebra like and put
it to it even though it is not at all
immediately obvious this guy here is a
perfect square not an obvious puppy
swear have a look though ok I can do the
easy part at first you're expecting like
an a squared plus or minus two MA and a
B squared right so what is it B Square
going to be it's four square so this is
plus 4 squared right yep so if that's
what B Square is this should be
accessories I guess this is minus 2a be
yes minus two times something x 4 so
what's a what would give me minus two
times something times portals
yeah good because I've got eight ER and
there's a two there it looks like i have
to divide by four that will give me that
i'll end up with the two there right it
will exactly cancel with that your honor
instead of adding X there as well and
they can't come from here obviously
there are no sides here and there xs so
it must come from here route seven on
what I just say 4x do you agree with
that it's a bit messy right but trust me
this is a suit yeah for what it's worth
if I'd be a whole of this he will be a
sir and if he is a whole number there
may be 16 equals a squared + 37 is two
times the export guy no it's not
coincidental at all so i will get to the
algebraic one in a minute but let's just
finish this up here I've just identified
this is the a and you can see it fits
with this doesn't it like this is my a
square so this looks like to me its root
7 on 4 X or square UK with that and
that's taking spirit so now the
factorization for the perfect square is
a little more obvious so what are they
going to get this is the square root of
a square the square root of what's
actually being swept 47 on 40 x x minus
take away 4 because I've got this
attractive looking good that's squared
and that's the square root now hopefully
I'm screwed you enough to know that when
you take the square root of a number the
square root of the square of know you're
just get the number back what do you get
you're the absolute value of a number so
it looks me I'm being this
that ok ok now for reasons are become
clear in a minute I'm actually going to
turn this around because do you agree
right that the absolute value odd for
instance right five take away three
don't tell me what the number is just do
it in your head do you see that this is
the same as this right do you agree with
that like because it's taking the
difference between the numbers inside
the absolute value size is a negative
and the absolute value takes the
negative out of play represent make
sense so i'm going to write it like this
for months that's yes now pause for a
minute that looks a whole lot simpler
than what we started with ok I want you
to look carefully and what will happen
when I do it with the other focus right
have a look what difference will it make
it's very very closer to them do you see
so because everywhere I would have put a
root set up reminders for itself ok so
in here there's going to be a loss in
seven minus that means in here instead
of a plus i'm going to get a minus that
doesn't affect with any of these doesn't
this look like terms there so that's
still going to be here it's still gonna
be here it's still going to be now at
this point that's where i got on minus
side problems he knows that so all the
way through all these minor signs they
would have been pluses there's a double
negative happy yeah so therefore i mean
you can do you all the way through i'm
just going to say similarly by exactly
the same bludging except with pluses and
minuses i'm going to say similarly PS
dash equals this guy
okay now we are almost there I know this
doesn't seem particularly obvious that
you would do this but remember i was
trying to get a relationship between the
distance to one focus and the distance
to the other right where you can see if
I just can't ever to get on like so
right can you see that there are two
parts that cancel each other out is the
negative air and the plus there so I'm
getting the absolute value of 8 which of
course is just eight now hold on a
second what have we just established
rewind all the way back to where we
began and what psps national are they
are the distances to what what are the
distances between what the distance
between a point and compared to one
focus and any other mark that any point
at all on the entire ellipse I was not
necessary with anyway okay anywhere at
all anywhere on there I'm going to get
this number so what this means is think
about this Levi the implication what
this means is that anywhere on their
lives if you compare the distance from
one focus to another you add them up
you're always going to get this constant
right it's completely irrespective of
where you are you still get the same
number